imagine that i'm standing here holding
the end of a rope
i'm over here on the left end and while
holding the rope i rapidly move my hand
up down and back to the starting
position
if we were to take a snapshot of the
rope immediately after i finished my
motion
we're going to see something like this
the rope has a squiggly disturbance
that mirrors the motion i made with my
hand up
down and back to the middle and the rest
of the rope is still flat
you might have seen something like this
if you've ever played with a jump rope
and wiggled it back and forth
or a slinky and you've seen that
oscillate back and forth on the ground
or if you've been in the gym and seen
somebody doing exercises with large
battle ropes
slamming them up and down repeatedly and
we know that over time this disturbance
is actually going to make its way
through the rope
if this is what we observe right after
my hand motion at some later point in
time we will observe that the beginning
of the rope is back to its original
shape
the squiggly disturbance has made its
way further down the rope
and it will keep traveling in this
direction until it reaches the end of
the rope
this is exactly what a wave is in
physics
a wave is a disturbance in this case the
squiggle on the rope
caused by my hand motion and that
disturbance can propagate
it can travel or move in a particular
direction
so a wave is a disturbance that can
propagate
this particular example is called a
mechanical wave
it's called a mechanical wave because
the disturbance is traveling through a
medium
in this case the rope so mechanical
waves travel through a medium
one important point about waves that is
worth noting right now
is that waves transfer energy without
transferring matter
so what that means is that the
disturbance that is moving here this
squiggly shape
is moving through the rope but it isn't
moving the rope to a different position
any part of the rope might go up and
down as a wave travels through that
section
but the rope itself is not going
anywhere rather
it's the kinetic energy imparted to the
rope by my hand
that is transferring from particle to
particle and making its way through the
rope
so waves transfer energy but not
matter so in my first example i only
jerked my hand up and down once
which created a single wave pulse that
moved through my rope
if instead i were to keep moving my hand
up and down consistently
i would see a waveform that looks
something like this and when we model a
wave
there are a few key characteristics that
we need to know about that wave
first is the period period is measured
in seconds
and it tells us how long it takes for
one wave cycle to complete
next is the wavelength measured in units
of distance like meters
the wavelength is the distance between
identical points of adjacent waves
and finally there's frequency so the
waveform that we've drawn here takes one
second
there are four cycles in that one second
that means it has a frequency of four
hertz or four cycles per second so the
frequency
measured in cycles per second tells us
how many wave cycles there are
every second now using just these basic
anatomical properties of a wave
we can start to figure out more
interesting physical characteristics
like speed
or distance over time if we want to know
how fast a wave is traveling
we can take its wavelength which is the
distance covered by a single cycle
and multiply that by the frequency which
is how many cycles are completed in a
second
a given amount of time the cycles cancel
out and we're left with units of
distance over time the same as speed
and that's our equation for the speed of
the wave wavelength
times frequency the standard units for
speed are meters per second
there are a couple factors that can
affect the speed of a wave the first is
the wave type
so different types of waves move at
different speeds
a relatable example of different waves
moving at different speeds is lightning
have you ever seen lightning strike or
been in a thunderstorm you know that the
first thing you see is the flash of
lightning
and then you hear the thunder associated
with that lightning flash
so the lightning comes first and the
thunder comes second
that's because those are two different
waves that are part of the same
phenomenon
when the lightning strike hits you see
the flash first because that's an
electromagnetic wave
light it travels much faster than the
sound associated with the lightning
strike
electromagnetic waves are special not
only because they travel really fast
but they also don't need a medium to
travel through
the thunder on the other hand is a sound
wave traveling slower than the light
so you'll see the lightning before you
hear the thunder
different wave types move at different
speeds
the second key factor that can affect
the speed of a wave is the medium
through which the wave travels
and we'll consider sound as an example
here so when someone is talking right we
have this talking head creating some
vibrations of the particles in front of
their mouth
that's the sound wave it's the vibration
of those particles
propagating through the air when you
speak your vocal cords exert force
on the particles just in front of you
they vibrate back and forth
creating a compression that transfers to
the surrounding particles
as the vibrations continue to propagate
the sound travels
you can imagine that if these particles
are packed closer together
those vibrations are going to transfer a
lot more quickly
because the particles are colliding much
faster than if they're further apart
so sound travels much faster in water a
liquid
than it does in air for that exact
reason the particles in the liquid are
closer together
since they're closer compacted they
collide more and the propagation of the
wave happens
faster so different waves move at
different speeds
and the medium through which a wave
travels can also affect the speed of a
wave
alright so let's try to summarize all
this information we have waves
a wave a disturbance that can propagate
and it has a few key characteristics
there's the period or how long it takes
one cycle to complete
there's the wavelength the distance
between identical points on two waves
that are next to each other
and the frequency which is how many wave
cycles complete in one second
in this case we have two cycles in one
second for a frequency of two hertz
wave speed is found by multiplying
wavelength and frequency
and that way speed is affected by the
type of wave and the medium through
which the wave travels
mechanical waves are ways that travel
through a medium so
sound a slinky or rope ocean waves
and electromagnetic waves like light are
special because they can travel through
a vacuum
they don't have to have a medium in
order to propagate
but all waves no matter what type
transfer
energy not matter